a psychology explanation for why
menopause exists it's called the
grandmother hypothesis grandmother
hypothesis says that why would you have
female animal that exists beyond their
reproductive window if our goal is to
survive and reproduce as soon as you
stop reproducing surely kicking the
bucket makes a ton of sense cuz get out
of the way let the calories go to the
ones that are going to be able to
survive if you can no longer make kids
but that doesn't account for the fact
that the very effortful rearing that's
required for human children if you
imagine that you have particular
fertility window after that point you as
grandmother can no longer produce
children that sap calories but can
contribute to the rearing of children
not only yours but your daughters and
your sisters and so on and so forth you
age out of your reproductive role and
move into a new kind of role so you are
still a net positive from a caloric
perspective to the whole tribe that's
fascinating it actually makes a lot of
sense but I don't know what the solution
is for the modern day woman